From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
There's this theater company in Chicago that, for years, put out a new show every single week where they performed 30 plays in 60 minutes, called the Neo-Futurists. And when we first broadcast today's program all the way back in 2003, a bunch of us were sitting around talking about that group. And one of us had just seen one of their shows. And we thought, that would be really fun-- 30 stories in 60 minutes? Let's try that.
芝加哥有一家剧团，多年来每周都会上演一场全新的演出，在60分钟内表演30出戏，他们叫“新未来主义者”。当我们2003年第一次播出今天的节目时，我们几个人坐在一起聊过这个团体。其中一个人刚看了他们的演出，我们当时想，那一定很有趣——60分钟讲30个故事？我们也来试试吧。
Instead of our usual-- each week we choose a theme, bring you three or four stories, blah, blah, blah, public radio, very reflective, what kinds of stories would we end up with if we did 30 in one hour? Or even 20? What would it sound like?
不同于我们平时的模式——每周选择一个主题，带来三四个故事，巴拉巴拉，公共广播，非常反思性——如果我们一小时讲30个故事，最后会是什么样？甚至20个？听起来会是什么样？
We honestly had no idea. And so, that's what we're going to do today. Today we're going to find out. And I have to say, time is wasting if we're going to fit everything in.
老实说我们完全没概念。所以，这就是我们今天要做的。今天我们要一探究竟。我得说，如果要塞进这么多内容，时间可耽误不得。
How many will it be? How many will we squeeze in? There is but one way to find out, and that is to stick around.
会有多少个？我们能塞进多少个？只有一个办法知道，那就是继续听下去。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: And let's begin with this one, Act One-- Don't I Know You? Throughout this hour we're going to be bringing you two-minute documentaries, fantastically short works of fiction, and all kinds of little stories that we ordinarily can't use on the radio show because they are just too short, even though they're really fun stories to listen to and perfect stories for the radio. Our first story is one like that. It's one of those stories-- you know how people you know have their greatest hits stories of things that happened to them? We went on a massive search for stories like that from all over the country, and this is one of the stories like that that we found.
第一幕——我不认识你吗？在接下来的这一小时里，我们将为大家带来两分钟的纪录片、极短的虚构作品，以及各种各样的短篇小故事，因为它们太短了，平时没法在节目里播，但它们听起来非常有趣，也非常适合电台播放。我们的第一个故事就是这类。你知道人们常有关于自己经历的“最佳精选”故事吗？我们在全国范围内进行了大规模搜寻，这就是我们找到的故事之一。
It happened to this actor named Tate Donovan. He told it to our producer Starlee Kine. He was out one night going to a Broadway play with a friend, being treated in this way he never gets treated.
这是演员泰特·多诺万的亲身经历。他告诉了我们的制片人斯塔莉·凯恩。那天晚上他和朋友去看百老汇演出，受到了他从未享受过的特殊待遇。
We're sitting around waiting for it to start. And I'm not a very-- I'm not a sort of a recognizable actor. I'm an actor who works, but I never get recognized.
我们坐着等演出开始。我并不是一个……我不是那种容易被认出来的演员。我是个有戏拍的演员，但我从没被认出来过。
So all of a sudden, the 10 minutes we're sitting there for it to start, three or four people come up to me and recognize me. I mean, they know exactly who I am. And they are quoting lines from a television show I was on. And like, hey, you were Joshua on Friends.
突然，在演出开始前的十分钟里，三四个人走过来认出了我。我的意思是，他们非常清楚我是谁，还引用了我在一部电视剧里的台词。比如，嘿，你是《老友记》里的乔舒亚。
And I've always admired stars who were really gracious. So you always think, that's what I want to be like. I want to be really friendly when I'm famous. So I wanted to be friendly and sweet, and go out to the people. They don't have to come to me all the time.
我一直很钦佩那些非常有礼貌的明星。所以你总是想，我以后也要那样。等我出名了，我要变得非常友好。所以我当时想表现得友好亲切，主动去接触人们。他们不必一直主动来找我。
[LAUGHS] So for a little window of time, though, you were exactly the kind of celebrity that you wanted to always be. You were gracious and reserved.
[笑] 但在那个短暂的瞬间，你表现得正是你一直想成为的那种名流。你既优雅又矜持。
Yeah, and warm, you know what I mean? I wasn't like one of these distant celebrities. I was like, hey, I was genuine. They all left thinking, that guy's a really great guy. He's so sweet.
是啊，而且很热情，你懂我的意思吗？我不想表现得像那种高高在上的名流。我就想，嘿，我很真诚。他们离开时一定觉得，那家伙真是个好人，他太贴心了。
I was exactly how I wanted to be. I was doing it. I was doing great.
我表现得正是我想要的样子。我做到了，我做得很好。
And then the kid with the camera came along. This nervous kid-- I don't know, he must have been 16 years old. He's in a rented tuxedo, unbelievably shy and awkward, and he's got acne. And he's got a camera in his hand.
然后那个带着相机的孩子出现了。那个紧张的孩子——我不知道，他肯定才16岁。他穿着租来的燕尾服，羞涩尴尬得难以置信，还满脸痤疮。他手里拿着相机。
And underneath the marquee is his date, who is in literally a prom dress, and she's got a corsage. And she's really nervous and sort of clutching her hands. And he sort of comes up to me and he sort of mumbles something about a picture.
遮阳篷下站着他的女伴，穿着真正的舞会礼服，戴着胸花。她很紧张，双手紧握。他走过来，含糊不清地说着想拍张照片。
And I just feel for him. So I'm like, absolutely, my gosh. Sure, no problem. My God, you poor thing. And I go up to his girlfriend and I wrap my arms around her.
我很同情他，所以我说，当然，天哪。没问题。天啊，你这可怜的孩子。我走上前去，搂住他女朋友的肩膀。
And I'm like, hey, where are you from? Fantastic, you going to see the play? That's great.
我说，嘿，你们从哪来的？太棒了，你们是来看戏的吗？真不错。
And the guy is sort of not taking the photograph very quickly. He's just sort of staring at me. And he's got his camera in his hands and it's down by his chin.
那小伙子并没有马上拍照。他只是盯着我。他手里拿着相机，放在下巴位置。
And she's very stiff and awkward. And I don't know what to do, so I just lean across, and I kiss her on the cheek. And I'm like, all right, come on, take the picture. Hurry up.
女方显得非常僵硬和尴尬。我不知道该怎么办，所以我凑过去，亲了亲她的脸颊。我说，好了，快点，拍照吧。快点。
And finally he sort of snaps it. And I'm like, OK, it was really wonderful to meet you. And he just stammered over to me and was like, um, [CLICKS TONGUE] could you take a picture of us?
最后他拍了下来。我说，好啦，很高兴见到你们。他结结巴巴地对我说了句，呃，[弹舌声] 你能帮我们拍张照吗？
[GROANS]
[呻吟]
And the whole time, he just wanted me to take a picture of him and his girlfriend underneath the awning of the play. He didn't want a picture of me. He had no idea who I was. [LAUGHS]
原来他全程只是想让我帮他和女朋友在戏院遮阳篷下拍张照。他根本不想拍我。他压根不知道我是谁。[笑]
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Oh, God. They were in shock. I don't think they'd ever come across a human being acting this way. I mean, could you imagine-- you ask someone to take a picture, and you just get in it yourself, and kiss them, and hey.
哦，天哪。他们都惊呆了。我觉得他们从未见过有人会这样。想象一下——你请人帮忙拍照，结果对方直接闯进镜头，还要亲你，还跟你自来熟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Tate Donovan with Starlee Kine.
泰特·多诺万与斯塔莉·凯恩。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Two-- No, Of Course I Know You. One of the things that's been really interesting about putting this show together this week is going to some of our regular contributors and commissioning stories that are just two or three minutes long from people who normally write stories that are 10 times that length. This story is an example of that, from Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City.
第二幕——不，我当然认识你。这周制作节目的过程中，最有趣的事情之一就是向我们的一些固定撰稿人约稿，邀请他们创作两三分钟的故事，而这些人平时写的稿子通常都是这个篇幅的十倍。这个故事就是一个例子，来自盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。
Who was that woman, that woman I just saw while walking out of the restaurant? She was sitting at a table by the door, glasses, a hat, like Lois Lane.
那个女人是谁？我刚才走出餐厅时看到的那个女人。她坐在门边的桌子旁，戴着眼镜，戴着帽子，看起来像露易丝·莱恩。
She looked at me like she knew me. And I said hello because I thought I recognized her. But I couldn't remember her name, so I just kept going out the door.
她看着我的眼神好像认识我。我说了声你好，因为我以为我认出她了。但我记不起她的名字，于是我就直接走出门口了。
Now I can't even remember how I know her. I know I know her, or used to know her. Somehow she was very important to me. She helped me out in a time of trouble.
现在我甚至记不起我是怎么认识她的了。我知道我认识她，或者曾经认识她。不知为何她对我非常重要。我在困难时期她曾帮助过我。
She used to roll her eyes. I'd say something dumb and she'd roll her eyes and get me something I needed, even though she didn't have to. Maybe she works in the library, or the county recorder's office, or at the newspaper.
她以前总是翻白眼。我说什么傻话她就会翻白眼，但还是会给我需要的东西，尽管她没必要这么做。也许她在图书馆、县记录员办公室或者报社工作。
I think I may have been in love with her. No, she's too young. I was never in love with her, not in that way. It's just that I wanted something, needed something. And she was able to give it to me, almost out of the goodness of her heart. And now I can't even remember who she is.
我想我可能曾经爱上过她。不，她太年轻了。我从来没爱上过她，不是那种爱。只是我当时想要什么，需要什么。而她几乎是出于好心给了我。现在我连她是谁都记不起来了。
I'm sick. I'm old. I should just walk out into traffic and kill myself. At home, at night, I go to sleep, searching for the lost memory.
我病了。我老了。我应该直接走到车流中自杀算了。晚上在家睡觉时，我总是搜寻那段丢失的记忆。
Did I meet her down by the river in a canoe, or was it on a ferry in southeastern Alaska, or at the Foreign Correspondents Club in Phnom Penh along the Mekong? She has something to do with water, with life, with mud.
我是在河边的独木舟上认识她的，还是在阿拉斯加东南部的渡轮上，又或是在湄公河畔金边的外国记者俱乐部？她肯定和水有关，和生活有关，和泥土有关。
I sleep poorly, turning and maybe even groaning in anguish. I don't care about the woman anymore. I'm worried for myself. I feel as if there's a black hole in my brain, and slowly but surely, it's swallowing all the memories of my life.
我睡不好，辗转反侧，甚至痛苦地呻吟。我不在乎那个女人了。我担心我自己。我觉得大脑里有个黑洞，正慢慢地、肯定地吞噬着我一生中所有的记忆。
I get up at 5:30 and drive to work in the dark. I feel terrible. I look like a piece of gum in the gutter.
我5点半起床，在黑暗中开车去上班。我感觉糟透了。我看起来像排水沟里的口香糖。
I pull in to Java Joe's to get some chemical help, and there she is behind the drive-up window. I want to tell her I love her, but I don't because it would be too weird. All I can say is, wow. And she rolls her eyes and gets me my cup of coffee.
我开车去Java Joe's寻求化学提神，她就在免下车窗口后面。我想告诉她我爱她，但我没说，因为那太奇怪了。我只能说，哇。她翻了个白眼，递给我那杯咖啡。
Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City. If you haven't heard his podcast yet, it's called Home of the Brave.
盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。如果你还没听过他的播客，名字叫《勇敢之家》。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Three-- It's Commerce That Brings Us Together. In 1997, Susan Drury and her husband moved to rural Tennessee, not too far from the Alabama line. They grew attached to the local radio station.
第三幕——商业让我们走到一起。1997年，苏珊·德鲁里和丈夫搬到了田纳西州的农村，离阿拉巴马州界线不远。他们对当地的广播电台产生了感情。
We couldn't really get any other radio stations at the house, but WKSR has a lot going for it-- the way they read the obituaries on the air, the way people call in during the tornado to tell everybody they're OK and where the roads are flooded, the ads from the same downtown stores over and over and over. And then there's the show we like best.
在家里我们收不到别的电台，但WKSR有很多可取之处——他们广播讣告的方式，龙卷风期间人们打进电话告诉大家他们平安无事、哪里的路被淹了，还有那些来自市中心同一家商店一遍又一遍的广告。然后还有我们最喜欢的节目。
Here we go. It's time once again for another edition of Swap and Shop here on WKSR.
开始吧。又是WKSR的《交换与购物》节目时间了。
Swap and Shop is a low-tech, personable sort of Ebay. It's not fancy or particularly well-produced or anything. It's just a show where people call in to say what they want to sell or buy or give away. They give their phone number, and that's it.
《交换与购物》是一个低技术、亲民版的eBay。它不花哨，制作也不精良。它只是一个让人们打电话来说想买、卖或赠送什么的节目。他们报上电话号码，就这么简单。
Swap And Shop, good morning.
《交换与购物》，早上好。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #1: Good morning, I have a couch for sale I need to advertise.
广播听众 #1：早上好，我有个沙发要卖，想做个广告。
OK.
好的。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #1: It's a Lane recliner couch. It's six weeks old. It listed for $1,140, and I'll sell it for $600. We've just got one too many.
广播听众 #1：这是Lane牌躺椅沙发。用了六周。原价1140美元，我卖600美元。我们家沙发多了一个。
OK, and your phone number?
好的，电话号码是多少？
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #1: 468-2524.
广播听众 #1：468-2524。
All right, sir, thank you for calling.
好的，先生，谢谢你的来电。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #1: Thank you. Have a good day.
广播听众 #1：谢谢。祝你愉快。
You too. There's a couch for sale at 468-2524.
你也一样。有人要卖沙发，电话468-2524。
The show is hosted by a guy named Don Estep, and he almost never comments on anything people are trying to buy or sell. He's like a lot of my neighbors, particularly the men. The attitude is, your business is your business. There's no shame in tough times, and nobody turns himself inside out to tell you everything.
节目主持人叫唐·埃斯蒂普，他几乎从不对人们买卖的东西发表意见。他就像我的很多邻居一样，尤其是男人们。态度就是：你的事就是你的事。日子难过也不丢人，没人会把心掏出来告诉你所有细节。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #2: Yes, I have for sale a table and chairs, a microwave, and a washer and a bedroom suite. And I also want to buy a car, a small car.
广播听众 #2：是的，我要卖一套桌椅、一台微波炉、一台洗衣机和一套卧室家具。我还想买辆车，小车。
OK, there's a table and chairs.
好的，有一套桌椅。
Mostly you're just left to wonder about the story behind these things. You don't get too many answers.
大多数时候，你只能去猜测这些物品背后的故事。你不会得到太多答案。
Swap and Shop, good morning.
《交换与购物》，早上好。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #3: Yes, I'd like to buy a used trampoline. It doesn't matter what shape it's in or if it even has a tarp on it or not. And my telephone number is 629--
广播听众 #3：是的，我想买个二手蹦床。不管形状怎么样，有没有篷布都无所谓。我的电话号码是629——
Swap and Shop is not unique to this station. Local stations across the country have these radio classifieds type shows. WKSR's version has a regular segment called "The Doggone Show."
《交换与购物》并不是这个电台独有的。全国各地的当地电台都有这种广播分类广告节目。WKSR的版本有一个固定环节叫“狗狗秀”。
Folks have found a black, white, and brown young female beagle with a white tip on its tail, and, more than likely, a family pet. If you'll call 565-4505-- is that number. Also four cows have been found. And you think they might belong to you--
有人发现了一只黑白棕三色的小雌性比格犬，尾巴尖是白的，很可能是家养宠物。如果你打565-4505——号码就是这个。另外还发现了四头牛。如果你觉得可能是你家的——
That first winter in our house, we had no heat, which we thought was adventurous, but was, in fact, just cold. And when we heard a lady call in with an ugly but functional wood stove for sale for $75, we called her. We got it, and we were toasty.
搬进新房的第一个冬天，我们没有暖气，我们觉得这很冒险，但实际上只是冷。当我们听到一位女士打电话说要卖一个丑但实用的烧木炉，标价75美元时，我们买了它，然后我们全身就暖和了。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #4: Hey, Don, that little black and brown and white beagle with the tip on her tail that we found? Well, we lost her, so you can quit advertising-- on Barnett Road.
广播听众 #4：嘿，唐，我们发现的那只黑棕白相间、尾巴尖带白的小比格犬？我们把它丢了，所以你可以停止广告了——在巴尼特路上。
On the Barnett Road?
在巴尼特路上？
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #4: Yeah.
广播听众 #4：是的。
All right.
好的。
(SUBJECT) RADIO CALLER #4: Thank you.
广播听众 #4：谢谢。
Thank you for calling.
谢谢你的来电。
Susan Drury, Tennessee.
田纳西州的苏珊·德鲁里。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Four-- The Sound of One Hand Waving. For this one, let's go to the beach for a one-minute and four-second vacation on Nantucket Island.
第四幕——单手挥舞的声音。这次，让我们去海边，在南塔克特岛度过一分零四秒的假期。
[WAVES CRASHING]
[海浪拍打声]
When we were in the water and we realized we weren't able to get back in, we had some friends that were on the beach. And so we started waving to them. We were kind of doing this double-hand wave thing over our heads.
我们在水里意识到回不去了，海滩上有几个朋友。于是我们开始向她们挥手。我们双手举过头顶挥动。
And our friend just kept waving back. She was standing and talking to some other people on the beach. That must have happened two or three times. And we waved like crazy, and she waved back.
我们的朋友也一直挥手回应。她当时正站在那儿和别人聊天。这种情况肯定发生了两三次。我们疯狂地挥手，她也挥手回应。
And then when we got on the surfboard later, when the surfer picked us up and we still couldn't get in, we were waving again. And again she thought-- we asked her afterwards, why did you think we were waving? She said, we thought you were just trying to show us you were on the surfboard with this guy.
后来当我们上了冲浪板，冲浪者接我们时我们还是无法上岸，我们又在挥手了。她以为——我们事后问她，为什么以为我们在挥手？她说，我们以为你们只是想展示你们和这家伙在一起冲浪。
So I'm like, God, we're waving frantically to tell you what, that we're on a surfboard with some 19-year-old, and we're-- Nobody got it. And we were sufficiently panicked. And nobody saw anything but a bunch of middle-aged women at Fat Ladies Beach, waving to their friends.
所以我说，天哪，我们疯狂地挥手是在告诉你什么，告诉你在冲浪板上载着个19岁的小伙子吗？没人明白。我们确实非常恐慌。没人看到别的，只看到一群中年妇女在胖女人海滩向朋友挥手。
Patty Martin from Nantucket. She talked to Jim Sulzer. She has since passed away.
南塔克特的帕蒂·马丁。她和吉姆·萨尔泽聊过。她后来已经去世了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Five-- The Sound of No Hands Clapping. This one came from Vicki Merrick and Eric Kipp and Jay Allison, who's the voice you hear.
第五幕——没有双手鼓掌的声音。这来自于薇琪·梅里克、埃里克·基普和杰·埃里森，你听到的声音就是他的。
Listen.
听着。
[WET SUCTION CLAPS]
[湿漉漉的拍打声]
Scallops clapping on Martha's Vineyard.
玛莎葡萄园岛上扇贝在拍手。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Six-- Reaching Out With Radio. Blunt Youth Radio is this project where they work with incarcerated teenagers. This story comes from Long Creek Youth Development Center in South Portland, Maine.
第六幕——用广播沟通。布朗特青年电台是一个与被监禁青少年合作的项目。这个故事来自缅因州南波特兰的朗溪青少年发展中心。
And just imagine how this works-- you're a teenager. You're locked up. You're in juvenile detention. And this group comes to you and says they will help you make your own radio story on a subject that concerns you. What do you do that story about? Well, here's Joey.
想象一下这是怎么运作的——你是个青少年，被关起来了，在少管所。然后这群人来告诉你，他们会帮你制作关于你关心主题的广播故事。你会写什么故事？嗯，听听乔伊的。
Hi, I'm Joey, and I ate somebody's urine. It all started when I went to dinner at the cafeteria and someone told my friend not to eat the pudding. Then my friend told me, after I ate, that someone had peed in it. I survived that day, but I couldn't stop thinking about it. So I went to the cooks to see if they had an answer.
嗨，我是乔伊，我吃了别人的尿。这一切始于我去餐厅吃晚饭，有人告诉我朋友别吃布丁。然后我吃完后，朋友告诉我，有人往里撒尿了。那一天我活下来了，但我无法停止思考这个问题。所以我去找厨师看看他们有什么解释。
This is Joey and Jake. We're about to see if we can interview Bill Wyman on--
这是乔伊和杰克。我们正要去采访比尔·怀曼，关于——
Our food situation.
我们的饮食状况。
--people messing with our food.
——关于有人在我们的食物里动手动脚。
Yeah, we're not too happy.
是的，我们很不高兴。
We're not too happy. Excuse me, Mr. Wyman? I was wondering if I could interview you and talk to you about people putting-- if it happened-- glass in our pancakes and peeing in the pudding and stuff? We was wondering what you had to say about that.
我们很不高兴。打扰一下，怀曼先生？我想采访您，聊聊关于有人往——如果这是真的话——煎饼里放玻璃，往布丁里撒尿之类的事？我们想知道您对此有什么看法。
They don't. Nobody does that. You kids don't handle the food at all.
没有这种事。没人做那种事。你们这些孩子根本接触不到食物。
We heard that it was brought up at briefing that somebody put glass in the pancakes.
我们听说有人在会上提到有人往煎饼里放了玻璃。
No, that wasn't glass. It was a piece of plastic that came from one of the glasses out there in the dining room that you kids had.
不，那不是玻璃。那是你们这些孩子在餐厅用的一只杯子上的塑料碎片。
Do you know how it got into the pancake batter?
您知道它怎么进煎饼面糊里的吗？
It didn't get into the pancake batter. It was put in there afterwards.
它没进面糊。是后来放进去的。
Well, we heard different from other kids.
嗯，我们从别的孩子那里听到的不一样。
You hear different? Do you know anything about it?
你们听到的不一样？你们知道些什么吗？
We heard that it was--
我们听说它是——
Did you two have any idea, whatsoever, what's going on?
你们两个有任何头绪吗？到底发生了什么？
That's why we came to you, to get an idea.
所以我们才来找您，想了解一下。
No, that's not why you came to me. You came to me because you thought it was true.
不，那不是你们来找我的原因。你们来找我是因为你们以为那是真的。
Yeah, of course. If--
是啊，当然。如果——
Then you kept it going.
然后你们还在散播。
If somebody said that they messed with your food, joking or not, wouldn't you want to know really what happened or not?
如果有人说他们动了你的食物，不管是不是开玩笑，你难道不想知道到底发生了什么吗？
No, I would totally go with the kitchen, with the kitchen crew, and what you guys have been told.
不，我会完全相信厨房团队，相信你们被告知的情况。
So you'd believe the kitchen crew over the person? No matter how much credibility you can give them, you'd believe the kitchen crew over them? Even if--
所以你会相信厨房团队而不是当事人？不管对方的可信度有多高，你都信厨房团队？即使——
Of course, because you don't cook the food. You think it's funny, don't you? You really think it's funny.
当然，因为又不是你们在做饭。你们觉得这很有趣，对吧？你们真的觉得这很有趣。
No, I really don't think it's funny.
不，我一点也不觉得有趣。
Then why are you grinning like a Cheshire cat?
那你为什么笑得像只柴郡猫？
Because you're going friggin' zero to 10 just because we're asking a bunch of questions.
因为我们就问几个问题，您就气急败坏。
No, it's what you're asking. It's how you're asking the same thing over again. And you're trying to get an answer, which there isn't any answer there.
不，是因为你们问的问题。是因为你们一遍又一遍地问同样的事。你们想得到一个根本不存在的答案。
All right, this is obviously not working. I'm going to have to interview somebody else. I heard some kid got jumped because he supposedly peed in the pudding.
好吧，这显然行不通。我得去采访别人。我听说有个孩子因为据称往布丁里撒尿而被打了。
Supposedly. That's the key word right there-- supposedly.
据称。这就是关键——据称。
We have an investigator, and he investigated the incident. And we also had the pudding tested. They took it to an independent laboratory and tested it, and it was proven that there was no foreign matter in that pudding at all.
我们有调查员，他调查了这件事。我们还把布丁拿去化验了。他们送到了一家独立实验室进行检测，证明布丁里根本没有异物。
Now, perhaps you weren't told that because I don't think you're told everything. But it was sad that, because you thought there was, you incited a riot in the dining room and made a big mess that kids had to clean up that had nothing to do with it.
也许没人告诉你们这些，因为我觉得你们什么都不知道。但可悲的是，就因为你们以为有，你们在餐厅引发了一场骚乱，搞得一团糟，那些跟这事完全没关系的孩子还得去清理。
I don't know what to think. If someone did contaminate the food with bodily fluids, I guess I'd rather not know since I'm stuck here and I have to eat the food. Thank you for your time. This is Joey.
我不知道该怎么想。如果真有人用体液污染了食物，我想我还是不要知道的好，毕竟我被困在这，还得吃这里的饭。谢谢您的时间。这是乔伊。
Joey-- he was 18 when he recorded that story. His friend Jake was 16.
乔伊——他录这个故事时18岁。他的朋友杰克16岁。
If you're just tuning in, this is This American Life. We have tossed out our regular way of doing the show this week-- trashed it, chucked it, spurned it. We laugh at it, we spit on its grave. And instead, we are bringing you as many short stories as we can fit into 60 minutes. It is barely, what, 18 minutes into the show, and already we are at Act Seven, an incredible achievement.
如果你刚调到这个频道，这是《美国生活》。本周我们抛弃了常规的节目形式——把它撕碎、扔掉、摒弃。我们嘲笑它，向它的坟墓吐口水。取而代之的是，我们在60分钟内塞进尽可能多的短故事。节目才过去——怎么样，18分钟？我们已经到第七幕了，这简直是个奇迹。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Seven-- Up Where the Air is Clear. We have this story from Jonathan Goldstein.
第七幕——高处空气清新。我们有这个来自乔纳森·戈德斯坦的故事。
Before he ever moved to Gotham City, before he grew into the overweight, obsessive sad sack of his later years, the Penguin was a poet and a dandy who lived in London. He wrote complex villanelles and threw lavish dinner parties at which he only became more charming the more he drank. He wore a monocle, a top hat, and carried an umbrella.
在搬到哥谭市之前，在他长成后来那种肥胖、痴迷的丧气鬼之前，企鹅人曾是一位居住在伦敦的诗人和花花公子。他写过复杂的维拉内尔诗，举办过奢华的晚宴，酒喝得越多就越迷人。他戴着单片眼镜、高礼帽，随身带着一把雨伞。
One evening, at one of his dinner parties, after hours spent sipping absinthe, the Penguin ran up to the roof of his building, opened up his large black umbrella, and leaped off into the air. As he coasted to the ground, he hollered out lines from Blake, stuff about grabbing life by the fat of its stomach and giving it a twist. He was that crazy. He was that bursting with life.
一天晚上，在一次晚宴上，在喝了几个小时苦艾酒后，企鹅人跑到大楼屋顶，撑开他那把黑色大雨伞，跳进了空气中。当他滑向地面时，他高喊着布莱克的诗句，关于抓住生活胃部脂肪并给它一扭的内容。他就是那么疯狂。他就是那么充满生命力。
From that night on, he made it his habit to jump off roofs ever higher, while clutching an umbrella. After a while, he got pretty good at it, too. He saw that by kicking his legs and twisting his back a certain way, he could actually prolong his flight, coasting all over the place, sometimes only landing after several daring minutes aloft.
从那天起，他养成了抓着雨伞从越来越高的屋顶跳下的习惯。过了一阵子，他竟然跳得相当不错。他发现通过踢腿和以某种方式扭动背部，他实际上可以延长飞行时间，四处滑翔，有时敢在空中冒险飞行几分钟才着陆。
It came to pass that the Penguin started hearing more and more about a certain nanny named Mary Poppins. She too, he was told, had been floating around London hanging from an umbrella handle. Everywhere he went, the Penguin kept hearing about her, how it was simply insane that they had not met each other yet.
后来，企鹅人越来越多地听说了一位叫玛丽·波平斯的保姆。据他说，她也曾撑着一把雨伞在伦敦四处漂浮。无论去哪，企鹅人总能听到关于她的事，说他们还没见过面简直太不可思议了。
So finally, a dinner party was arranged by someone who knew them both. And on the evening of the party, the Penguin walked into the drawing room, saw Mary Poppins on the divan, doffed his top hat, and bowed low, as was his style in those days. He'd planned a few things to say and do when first meeting Mary Poppins. He thought he might lift up his umbrella as though challenging her to a duel. He imagined she would smile and take up her own frilly, perhaps pink, umbrella, and then together, they would dance about the room, leaping over furniture, parrying and thrusting, perhaps even winding things up, breathing heavily nose to nose.
最后，一位认识他们两个人的中间人安排了一场晚宴。在宴会当晚，企鹅人走进客厅，看到沙发上的玛丽·波平斯，脱下高礼帽，深深鞠躬，这在他当年的风格里很常见。他曾计划在初次见到玛丽·波平斯时说些什么、做些什么。他想他或许可以举起伞，好像挑战她进行决斗。他想象她会微笑着拿起她那把花哨、或许是粉红色的雨伞，然后他们一起在房间里跳舞，越过家具，格挡突刺，甚至可能鼻尖对着鼻尖，呼吸急促地结束这一切。
Instead what happened was the Penguin became very shy and quiet. As he stood there staring at her, his top hat felt needlessly clumsy, his monocle too small for his face. And the squinting needed to keep it in place was giving him a slight headache. For the first time in his life, the Penguin felt ludicrous.
结果却是企鹅人变得非常害羞和安静。当他站在那盯着她看时，他的高礼帽感到多余而笨拙，单片眼镜对于他的脸来说太小了。为了固定它而进行的眯眼让他有点头疼。这是企鹅人人生中第一次感到自己很可笑。
I imagine you two must have an infinite amount of things to speak of, said their host as he sat them together at the dinner table. The Penguin nodded uncertainly. After three or four minutes, it became clear that the Penguin and Mary Poppins had absolutely nothing to say to one another that did not deal exclusively with umbrella travel-- getting stuck in trees, the shoulder aches, anxiety about tipping over in the wind.
“我想你们两个一定有聊不完的话题，”他们的主人让他们坐在一起吃饭时说道。企鹅人不安地点了点头。三四分钟后，很明显，企鹅人和玛丽·波平斯根本没有什么可说的，除非全是关于雨伞旅行——被卡在树里、肩膀酸痛、担心在风中翻倒。
Everyone at the table just sat there, staring at them expectantly, which made the whole thing even more awkward. Trying to move things along, Mary Poppins asked the Penguin if he liked to sing, to which the Penguin responded, only when I'm drunk. Then she asked if he enjoyed children, to which he replied, yes, in a sweet wine sauce.
桌上的每个人都坐在那，期待地盯着他们，这让场面更尴尬了。为了打破僵局，玛丽·波平斯问企鹅人喜不喜欢唱歌，企鹅人回答说：只有喝醉的时候。然后她问他喜不喜欢孩子，他回答说：喜欢，用甜酒酱烹饪的那种。
The Penguin then asked Mary Poppins how she kept people from looking up her skirt when she flew. She smiled politely, then turned to the man on her left and asked him how he was enjoying the lamb. The man on her left was wearing an elegant, aristocratic cape. Mary, a bit drunk on the sherry, noted that if he spread his cape out, he might be able to glide about like a bat. The man on her left chuckled and suggested that, after dinner, they head up to the roof and give it a try, which they did.
企鹅人接着问玛丽·波平斯当她飞行时是怎么防止别人看她裙子底下的。她礼貌地笑了笑，然后转向左边的男人，问他觉得羊肉怎么样。她左边的男人穿着优雅的贵族披风。玛丽喝了点雪利酒，有点上头，随口说如果他把披风撑开，或许能像蝙蝠一样滑翔。她左边的男人笑了笑，建议餐后他们去屋顶试试，于是他们真的去了。
Jonathan Goldstein-- he's the host of the podcast Heavyweight, which feels exactly like this story except the people in it are not fictional.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦——他是播客《重量级》的主持人，感觉就像这个故事一样，只是里面的人不是虚构的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Eight-- the Greatest Dog Name in The World. Yes, we have the true story of its origin. Years ago, an exclusive told by two brothers, one of whom is 12, the other is 13.
第八幕——世界上最伟大的狗名。没错，我们要讲这个名字起源的真实故事。几年前，由两兄弟讲述的独家报道，一个12岁，另一个13岁。
I wanted to name him Pasta. I used to like pasta a lot. And it was probably the first thing that came to my mind, so out of nowhere, I said Pasta. So he said Batman.
我想叫他“意大利面”。我以前很喜欢意大利面。这可能是我想到的第一件事，所以毫无预兆地我就说了“意大利面”。于是他说“蝙蝠侠”。
I wanted to name him Batman because I saw, in a movie, the dog stuck his head out the window and his ears went straight up. And it looked like-- it reminded me of Batman.
我想叫他“蝙蝠侠”是因为我看电影时，狗狗把头伸出窗外，耳朵竖得直直的。看起来——让我想到了蝙蝠侠。
And we fought over it for a little bit.
我们为此争论了一会儿。
I just remember running around and chasing each other. I was jumping on my mom's bed, saying, Batman, Batman, Batman. And then my brother was sitting in the chair, saying, Pasta, Pasta, Pasta. And that must have gone on for an hour.
我只记得我们在四处乱跑、互相追逐。我跳上妈妈的床，喊着：蝙蝠侠，蝙蝠侠，蝙蝠侠。然后我弟弟坐在椅子上，喊着：意大利面，意大利面，意大利面。这肯定持续了一个小时。
I think it was right around the time we had this big fight about gumballs, which I'm not going to get into because it was pretty embarrassing. But if there was just some little thing that we couldn't agree on, then it would just blew up into this whole big thing.
我想那正好是我们为口香糖大吵一架的时候，我不打算细说，因为挺尴尬的。但如果只是为了某件我们无法达成一致的小事，它就会演变成一件大闹剧。
Yeah, I remember being pretty upset about it. And then my mom comes in and says, all right, that's it. It's over. It's Pasta Batman. That's it.
是的，我记得为此很沮丧。然后我妈走进来，说：行了，就这样。名字就是“意大利面蝙蝠侠”。就这样。
And then there was silence. And then from there, he was Pasta Batman Lotze. Pasta. [CLAPS] Come on, Pasta Batman.
然后是一阵沉默。从那时起，他就成了“意大利面蝙蝠侠·洛茨”。意大利面。[拍手] 来吧，意大利面蝙蝠侠。
Pasta, here. Pasta Batman. Hey, good doggie.
意大利面，过来。意大利面蝙蝠侠。嘿，好狗狗。
Their names? Valion and Paris Lotze, age 12 and 13. They spoke with Katia Dunn.
他们的名字？瓦里恩和帕里斯·洛茨，12岁和13岁。他们接受了卡蒂亚·邓恩的采访。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Nine-- Of Dogs and Men. Elaine Boehm used to work at a pet shop.
第九幕——狗与人。伊莱恩·波姆以前在一家宠物店工作。
We've had to help people select items for their animals. And this woman and her husband came in. She was looking for a training collar, the pinch collar type. And, of course, they're pretty hideous looking, but they do do the job. And they don't hurt the animal, they just get the animal's attention.
我们必须帮人们挑选动物用品。这天一对夫妇走了进来。她正在找项圈，那种刺突项圈。当然，它们看起来很恐怖，但确实有用。它们不会伤害动物，只是引起动物的注意。
Well, she couldn't make up her mind what size to get. So she looked over to her husband and she said, dear, come over here. And then she looked at me and she said, his neck is about the same size as the dog. Put this on, she says.
好吧，她无法决定买什么尺寸。于是她看向丈夫说：亲爱的，过来。然后她看向我，说：他的脖子跟这只狗差不多大。把它戴上，她说。
And the guy stood there and took it as she puts the prong pinch collar around his neck. And she gives him a yank.
那男的站在那，任由她把刺突项圈套在他脖子上。她猛地一拉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says, yes, sweetheart, this works. This works. Thank you very much. That was the end of that.
他说道：是的，亲爱的，这招管用。管用。非常感谢。事情就这样结束了。
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[鸟鸣声]
Elaine Boehm talked with Jim Sulzer.
伊莱恩·波姆和吉姆·萨尔泽聊过。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 10-- so let's close out this part of our show before the break with a story from the theater group that gave us the idea for today's jam-packed little program in the first place-- that group, again, the Neo-Futurists. Every single week for over two decades, they did these shows where they would perform 30 plays in 60 minutes. Turns out you can get across a surprising amount in a two-minute play.
第十幕——让我们在休息前结束这部分节目，带来那个给了我们今天这个节目灵感的剧团的故事——再次提到那个团体，“新未来主义者”。二十多年来，他们每周都表演这种“60分钟内30出戏”的剧。事实证明，你在一个两分钟的戏剧里可以表达出惊人的内容。
Some of their plays are monologues, some of them are scenes. But a lot of them just take some simple concept, one idea, and then spin that concept out on stage for two minutes. This one's like that.
有些戏是独白，有些是场景。但很多只是采用一个简单的概念，一个想法，然后在舞台上将其延伸两分钟。这一个就是这样。
Statement, statement, statement-- question?
陈述，陈述，陈述——疑问句？
Agreement.
赞同。
Reassured statement, confident statement, confident statement. Overconfident statement.
重申的陈述，自信的陈述，自信的陈述。过度自信的陈述。
Question?
疑问句？
Elaborate defensive excuse.
精心编造的防御性借口。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Half-hearted agreement.
半推半就的赞同。
Insecure statement, distracted statement, absurd statement.
不自信的陈述，心不在焉的陈述，荒谬的陈述。
Clarification question?
澄清性疑问句？
Panicked [BLEEP] explanation! Quick, meaningless comic non-sequitur.
惊慌失措的[哔]解释！快速、无意义的喜剧非逻辑。
[LAUGHING] Laughter.
[大笑] 笑声。
[LAUGHS] Fake laughter, fake laughter.
[笑] 假笑，假笑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Accidental compliment of physical characteristics.
对身体特征的意外恭维。
Pleased response.
欣喜的反应。
[GASPS] Shocked continuation of meaningless comic non-sequitur.
[倒吸气] 震惊地继续说出无意义的喜剧非逻辑。
[LAUGHING] Laughter.
[大笑] 笑声。
[LAUGHING] Relieved laughter.
[大笑] 如释重负的笑声。
Laughter.
笑声。
Relieved laughter.
如释重负的笑声。
Superficial compliment.
敷衍的恭维。
Self-assured agreement as denial.
以否定作为自信的赞同。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Exaggerated statement, exaggerated statement, grossly exaggerated statement.
夸张的陈述，夸张的陈述，极其夸张的陈述。
Clarification question?
澄清性疑问句？
Extremely exaggerated elucidation.
极其夸张的阐释。
Mental compliment with accidental double entendre.
心理上的恭维，带有一点偶然的双关语。
[LAUGHING] Confident laughter.
[大笑] 自信的笑声。
Laughter.
笑声。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Embarrassed laughter.
尴尬的笑声。
Confident suggestive proposition.
自信且暗示性的提议。
Violent denial!
愤怒的否认！
Aghast repetition as question?
惊恐的重复作为疑问句？
Disgusted violent denial.
厌恶且愤怒的否认。
Defensive incriminating implication.
防御性的指控暗示。
Offended retort.
被冒犯的反驳。
Aggressive childish insult.
充满攻击性的幼稚侮辱。
Disbelieving rhetorical question?
难以置信的反问句？
Aggressive childish insult.
充满攻击性的幼稚侮辱。
Stunned silence.
目瞪口呆的沉默。
Aggressive childish insult.
充满攻击性的幼稚侮辱。
Defensive childish response!
防御性的幼稚回应！
Aggressive childish insult!
充满攻击性的幼稚侮辱！
Defensive childish response!
防御性的幼稚回应！
Aggressive childish--
充满攻击性的幼稚——
Defensive childish--
防御性的幼稚——
Attempted condescending conclusive statement.
试图以傲慢的总结性陈述结尾。
Brilliant scathing remark with literary allusion and long-term devastating scatological implication.
带有文学典故和长远毁灭性排泄物含义的绝妙刻薄话。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Pathetic self-revelation.
可悲的自我揭露。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Greg Allen and Heather Riordan from Too Much Light Makes the Baby Go Blind: 30 Plays in 60 Minutes, which ran every weekend in Chicago for 28 years until it ended its run in 2016. The Neo-Futurists have a new show, which also features lots of little two-minute plays. It is called The Infinite Wrench. Their website-- neo-futurists.org.
格雷格·艾伦和希瑟·里奥丹的《太多的光会让婴儿失明：60分钟30出戏》，该剧在芝加哥每个周末上演28年，直到2016年结束。“新未来主义者”有一个新节目，也包含很多两分钟的小戏，叫《无限扳手》。他们的网站是 neo-futurists.org。
Coming up, David Sedaris on an important-- and I have to say-- undiscussed question about cell phone use, and so many, so many other little stories, I don't even want to count them, in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯将探讨关于手机使用的一个重要且没人讨论过的问题，以及更多、更多的小故事，我都不想数了，一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，芝加哥公共广播。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Well, this is turning out to be an interesting show, isn't it? It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And if you're just tuning in, this week we are throwing out our regular way of doing things-- you know, three or four stories on some theme, blah, blah, blah. To hell with all that.
第十一幕——好吧，这节目变得越来越有趣了，不是吗？这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚调到这个频道，本周我们抛弃了常规的做事方式——你知道，围绕一个主题讲三四个故事什么的，见鬼去吧。
Instead, we are trying to cram as many stories into one hour as we humanly can. We guarantee 20. There may be more. We are at number 11, Etiquette Lesson. Here's writer David Sedaris.
相反，我们试图在这一小时内塞进尽可能多的故事。我们保证会有20个。可能更多。我们现在进行到第11号，“礼仪课”。这里是作家大卫·塞达里斯。
In a men's room at LaGuardia Airport, I watched a man take his cell phone from his jacket pocket, step into an empty stall, and proceed to dial. I thought he had come for the relative privacy, but looking through the space beneath the door, I saw that his pants were gathered about his ankles. He was sitting on the toilet.
在拉瓜迪亚机场的男厕所里，我看到一个男人从夹克口袋里掏出手机，走进一个空隔间，开始拨号。我还以为他只是为了找个相对私密的空间，但透过门下的缝隙看进去，我看到他的裤子堆在脚踝处。他正坐在马桶上。
Most airport calls began with geography. I'm in Kansas City, people say. I'm in Houston. I'm at Kennedy. When asked where he was, the man on the phone said simply, I'm at the airport. What do you think?
大多数机场通话都是从地理位置开始的。“我在堪萨斯城，”人们会说。“我在休斯顿。”“我在肯尼迪机场。”当被问到在哪时，电话里的那个人简单地说：“我在机场。你觉得呢？”
The sounds of a public toilet are not the sounds you would generally associate with an airport, and so his 'what do you think' struck me as unfair. The person he was talking to obviously felt the same way. What do you mean what airport, the man said. I'm at LaGuardia. Now put me through to Marty.
公共厕所的声音通常不会让人联想到机场，所以他的“你觉得呢”让我觉得很不公平。电话那头的人显然也这么想。“什么叫什么机场，”那人说。“我在拉瓜迪亚。现在帮我转接马蒂。”
A few hours later, I was in Boston relating the story to my sister, Tiffany. I mean, he actually placed a call while sitting on the toilet. Tiffany is big on rules, and so I expected a certain degree of outrage. I wanted disgust, but instead, she said only, I don't believe in cell phones. But you do believe in talking on the phone while sitting on the toilet?
几个小时后，我在波士顿向我姐姐蒂芙尼讲述了这个故事。我说，他是坐在马桶上打电话的。蒂芙尼非常讲究规矩，所以我预料她会有一定程度的愤慨。我想要的是厌恶，但她只说：“我不相信手机。” “那你相信坐在马桶上打电话吗？”
Well, it's not a belief, she said, but I mean, sure. When asked how she explains the noise, Tiffany scrunched up her face and held an imaginary receiver to her mouth. I say, (STRAINING) don't mind me, I'm just trying to get the lid off this jar.
“嗯，这不是信不信的问题，”她说，“但我的意思是，当然。当被问到怎么解释那些噪音时，”蒂芙尼皱起脸，对着嘴做了一个假想的听筒。“我会说，（用力地）别介意，我只是想把这个罐子的盖子拧开。”
Her face returned to normal and I thought of all the times I had fallen for that line, all the times I had pictured my sister standing helpless in her kitchen. Try tapping the lid against the countertop, I'd said, or rinse it in hot water, that sometimes works. Eventually, after much struggle, she would let out a breath. There we go, she'd say. I've got it now. And then she would say thank you. And I'd hang up thinking, well, it's a good thing she called me.
她的脸恢复正常，我想起我曾经多少次被这句话骗倒，多少次想象我姐姐在厨房里手足无措。“试着在台面上敲敲盖子，”我说过，“或者用热水冲一下，有时管用。”最终，经过一番挣扎，她会呼出一口气。“好了，”她会说。“现在弄开了。”然后她会说谢谢。而我挂断电话时会想，好吧，幸好她给我打了电话。
David Sedaris. His new book Calypso comes out this May.
大卫·塞达里斯。他的新书《卡吕普索》将于今年五月出版。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 12-- To Tell the Truth. This was recorded by Brent Runyon in the kids' section of the public library.
第十二幕——说真话。这是布伦特·鲁尼恩在公共图书馆童书区录制的。
My parents punish me so many times because I lie.
我父母惩罚我很多次，因为我说谎。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, I was home one day and I tripped over my brother-- well, OK, don't tell anybody this. I jumped over my brother's chair. I jumped--
好吧，有一天我在家，我在我兄弟身上绊倒了——好吧，行了，别告诉任何人。我跳过了我兄弟的椅子。我跳——
You did?
真的吗？
Yeah.
真的。
You lied to me?
你对我撒谎了？
I told you I jumped.
我告诉你我跳过去了。
No, you didn't.
不，你没有。
I told you the first day I got my crutches.
我拿到拐杖的第一天就告诉你了。
No, you did not.
不，你绝对没有。
Oh.
哦。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 13-- More Lies. This happened to Catherine and her husband John long before they were married, back before they graduated from college.
第十三幕——更多的谎言。这件事发生在凯瑟琳和她丈夫约翰结婚很久之前，还在他们大学毕业之前。
Girls babysit a lot and boys don't. And girls understand that, when you babysit, part of the deal is that you get to eat anything you want. So after we'd put the kids to bed, I said, well, we should go see what they have to eat.
女孩子经常做保姆，男孩子不做。女孩子明白，当你做保姆时，交易的一部分就是你可以随便吃你想吃的任何东西。所以在把孩子们送上床后，我说，嗯，我们该去看看他们有什么吃的。
And he said, we can't eat their food. And I said, of course we can eat their food. What do you mean? And he said, that's stealing.
他说，我们不能吃他们的食物。我说，我们当然可以吃。你什么意思？他说，那是偷窃。
I said, John, I promise you, it's fine to eat something. They expect us to. They understand that-- they don't expect us to starve while we're babysitting.
我说，约翰，我向你保证，吃点东西没关系。他们指望我们吃。他们明白——他们不希望我们在做保姆时挨饿。
And finally, he said, well, we can eat something, but only something they won't miss. And they had a huge crate full of grapefruits, and they also had cans and cans of black beans.
最后，他说，好吧，我们可以吃点东西，但只能吃他们不会发现少掉的东西。他们有一大箱葡萄柚，还有几罐黑豆。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[LAUGHS] So I had half a grapefruit. And John opened up a can of black beans and had that. And then I wrapped up the other half of the grapefruit. And John cleaned-- well, rinsed out and dried off the empty can of black beans. And we put the wrapped-up half a grapefruit and the cleaned out can of black beans in his bag.
[笑] 所以我吃了半个葡萄柚。约翰打开了一罐黑豆吃掉了。然后我把剩下的一半葡萄柚包起来。约翰把空黑豆罐洗干净擦干。我们把包好的半个葡萄柚和洗干净的空黑豆罐放进他的包里。
[LAUGHING] So that people wouldn't know that you had eaten anything?
[大笑] 所以别人就不会知道你们吃了什么？
We had destroyed the evidence. And this--
我们销毁了证据。而这——
At his insistence?
是在他的坚持下？
Yes, it was absurd. And then we watched TV, our hunger satisfied. And then the couple came home, and we made small talk.
是的，这太荒谬了。然后我们看了电视，填饱了肚子。接着那对夫妇回家了，我们闲聊了一会儿。
And then John picked up his bag in the hallway and there was a sort of dull thud, and half the grapefruit fell out on the floor. And I said, oh, that's mine. I'm sorry, I-- uh, we're allowed to take a piece of fruit from the dining hall. And I had taken that grapefruit from the dining hall, and that's why I have it here.
然后约翰在走廊拿起包，发出了一声沉闷的撞击声，半个葡萄柚掉在地板上。我说，哦，那是我的。对不起，我……呃，我们被允许从食堂带一个水果。我从食堂拿了那个葡萄柚，这就是为什么我有那个。
And then they sort of said, oh, OK, OK, that's nice. And then I put it back in John's bag. And then John picked up his bag again, and there was-- you guessed it-- a clang. And clanging out onto the floor went this empty can of black beans.
然后他们就说，哦，好的，好的，那挺好。然后我把它放回约翰的包里。接着约翰又拿起包，就——你猜对了——发出了一声当啷声。那个空黑豆罐当啷着掉在地板上。
And when the can fell out on the floor, John said, oh, that's mine. I keep change in that. Like, I keep change-- [LAUGHS] as if that was less insane.
罐子掉地上时，约翰说，哦，那是我的。我把零钱放在里面。就像，我把零钱放在里面——[笑] 好像这听起来没那么疯狂。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 14-- Call in Colonel Mustard For Questioning, Or That's What Happens If You Don't Use a Condiment, Kids. See all the stupid jokes that you end up telling if you have a story that takes place in a hot dog factory about hot dogs? Here we go.
第十四幕——叫芥末上校来审问，或者这就是不加调料的结果，孩子们。看看如果你在热狗工厂里讲热狗的故事，会讲出多少愚蠢的笑话。开始吧。
My name is Jim Bodman and I'm the chairman of the Vienna Sausage Company in Chicago. And the building that we are currently standing in, which is on the north side of Chicago, on Damen near the corner of Fullerton, was built around 1970.
我叫吉姆·博德曼，我是芝加哥维也纳香肠公司的主席。我们目前站的这座大楼，位于芝加哥北区，达门大街靠近富勒顿街角，建于1970年左右。
This hot dog plant, Jim Bodman says, replaced the company's original facility.
吉姆·博德曼说，这个热狗工厂取代了公司最初的设施。
So it was put together in a Rube Goldberg kind of arrangement. So we moved into this building. And this was a brand new, state of the art, stainless steel, refrigeration is perfect, spit clean building. And we started making our natural, old-world hickory smoked, natural-casing hot dogs here. And it wasn't as good.
所以它是以鲁布·戈德堡式的安排拼凑在一起的。我们搬进了这栋大楼。这是全新的、最先进的、不锈钢的、制冷完美、一尘不染的大楼。我们开始在这里制作我们的天然、旧世界山核桃木烟熏、天然肠衣热狗。但味道没那么好了。
They tasted OK, he says, but they didn't have the right snap when you bit into them. And even worse, the color was wrong. The hot dogs were all pink instead of bright red. So they tried to figure out what was wrong.
他说，味道还可以，但咬下去没有那种正确的弹性。更糟的是，颜色不对。热狗全是粉红色的，而不是鲜红色。所以他们试图找出问题所在。
The ingredients were all the same, the spices were all the same, the process was all the same. Maybe it was the temperature in the smokehouse. Maybe the water on the north side of Chicago wasn't the same as the water on the South side.
配料都一样，调料都一样，流程也一样。也许是烟熏房的温度问题。也许是芝加哥北区的水和南区的不一样。
They searched. They searched for a year and a half. Nothing checked out.
他们搜寻。他们找了一年半。什么都没发现。
Then one night, a bunch of guys from the plant are out having a drink, gabbing about the good old days, back in the old plant on Maxwell Street. They start talking about this guy named Irving, one of those guys who knows everybody in the plant, has nicknames for everybody. And listen to what Irving's job was. Every day, he would weave his way with the uncooked sausages through the maze of passageways in the old plant.
然后一天晚上，工厂里的一帮伙计出去喝酒，聊起在麦克斯韦街老工厂的往事。他们开始谈论一个叫欧文的家伙，那种在工厂里认识每个人、给每个人起绰号的人。听听欧文的工作是什么。每天，他都要穿过老工厂错综复杂的通道，带着未煮熟的香肠穿梭。
He would go through the hanging vents. That's where we hang the pastrami pieces, and it's quite warm. And he would go through the boiler room, where we produced all the energy for the plant. He would go next to the tanks where we cook the corned beef, finally get around the corner, and in some cases, actually go up an elevator. And then he would be at the smokehouse. He would put it in the smokehouse and he would cook it.
他会经过悬挂通风口。那是我们挂熏牛肉的地方，非常暖和。他会经过锅炉房，我们为工厂生产能量的地方。他会经过我们煮咸牛肉的罐子旁边，最后绕过拐角，在某些情况下，甚至要坐电梯。然后他会到达烟熏房。他会把它放进烟熏房，然后把它煮熟。
And as they were telling stories about Irving-- Irving this, Irving that-- a light bulb goes off. In the fancy new modern plant, there was no Irving. Irving didn't want to commute to the north side.
就在他们讲欧文的故事时——欧文这，欧文那——灯泡亮了。在豪华的新现代化工厂里，没有欧文。欧文不想通勤去北区。
There was no maze of hallways. There was no half-hour trip where the sausage would get warm before they would cook it. In the new plant, they just stuffed the sausages in a cold room and cooked them in a smokehouse in the room next door to it. Irving's trip was the secret ingredient that made the dogs red. So secret, even the guys who ran the plant didn't know about it.
没有迷宫般的走廊。没有那半小时的旅程，香肠在煮之前不会变热。在新工厂，他们只是把香肠塞进冷库，然后在隔壁房间的烟熏房煮熟。欧文的旅程是让热狗变红的秘密配料。如此隐秘，连管理工厂的人都不知道。
So we said, oh, my God, that is, of course, the reason. Why didn't we know that? That's the dumbest thing in the world to not realize. It's right there.
所以我们说，天哪，当然是这个原因。我们怎么会不知道？这是世界上最笨的事情，居然没意识到。它就在那。
How do we fix it? And the solution to the problem was the room that we're standing in right now. And this was a new addition put onto the plant about two years after we built the facility.
我们怎么修复它？这个问题的解决方案就是我们现在站的这个房间。这是我们在大楼建成约两年后增加的设施。
So you had to build this room?
所以你必须建这个房间？
This whole room-- the outside bearing wall is that wall right there. We put this whole room on. And in this room, we emulate the old area of the old plant.
整个房间——外面的承重墙就是那面墙。我们加建了整个房间。在这个房间里，我们模拟了老工厂的旧区域。
And so this room, essentially, is to simulate Irving?
所以这个房间本质上是为了模拟欧文？
That's exactly right. We should have called it Irving-- Irving's Corner.
完全正确。我们本应该叫它“欧文”——“欧文角”。
It's warm in Irving's corner, and it smells nice, too-- smoky, like hickory smoke and spices. Since I first heard this story years ago on a tour of this very plant, I found myself telling it now and then. I think that what I love about it is the fact that these guys at the factory had done everything right-- finally built their dream factory with the best equipment and expertise that money could buy. But you can't think of everything. Sometimes you have no idea why you were a success in the first place.
“欧文角”很暖和，闻起来也很棒——烟熏，像山核桃木烟味和香料。自从几年前我参观这家工厂时第一次听到这个故事，我偶尔就会讲它。我想我喜欢它是因为这些工厂的人做对了所有事——最终用金钱能买到的最好的设备和专业知识建造了他们的梦想工厂。但你不可能想到所有事情。有时你根本不知道当初为什么会成功。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 15-- Mr. Prediction. In the mid-1980s, right out of college, David Rakoff moved to Japan and pretty soon ended up in this office job where he was convinced that he understood a secret about the company and its business that nobody else, not even the big bosses at the company, could see. It was like that from the start.
第十五幕——预测先生。80年代中期，大学刚毕业，大卫·拉科夫搬到了日本，很快得到了一份办公室工作，他深信自己掌握了一个关于公司及其业务的秘密，别人甚至连公司的大老板们都看不出来。一开始就是这样。
Primarily, the office was an advertising agency. But what they were setting up was this thing for expatriates who were living in Tokyo at the time, or perhaps all of Japan. And it was like a network on a computer. And they would set up a newsletter on the network, and people could quote, "log on" to the computer and talk to one another, or do research.
主要是，这是一家广告代理公司。但他们当时正在为生活在东京，或者可能整个日本的外籍人士建立这个东西。它就像一台电脑上的网络。他们会在网络上建立一个通讯，人们可以引用，“登录”到电脑上互相交谈，或者做研究。
And I was just-- I don't know, I just looked around the room and I saw these computers and could only think, what kind of loser would log on to a computer, talk to someone? Then, in fact, that night in my diary, I had written something like, this is like those comic book enthusiasts who actually read the little instructions at the bottom of the panel that said, for more on the Green Goblin, check out Spidey #137, from the editor.
我只是——我不知道，我环顾房间，看到这些电脑，只能想，什么样的人会登录电脑去跟别人说话？后来，那一晚在日记里，我写道：“这就像那些真正的漫画书爱好者阅读面板底部的小指令，说：更多关于绿魔的信息，请查看《蜘蛛侠》第137期，编辑留。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And in almost the only moment of decisiveness in my entire adult life-- I've certainly never equaled this-- I went in the next morning and I quit. And all I could think was, sayonara, suckers. Good luck with your network. And we know exactly what the network was. It was the internet.
在我成年生活中几乎唯一一次果断时刻中——我当然从未达到过这种水平——我第二天早上进去就辞职了。我当时想的只是：永别了，傻瓜们。祝你们的网络好运。而我们确切地知道那网络是什么。它是互联网。
I have a negative capacity to identify trends. Like, when in college, I went to see Madonna at Danceteria, which was a club downtown, in like 1982 or whatever. And I thought, boy, is she lousy.
识别趋势，我有着负面的能力。就像大学时，我去Danceteria看麦当娜表演，那是个市中心的俱乐部，大概是1982年吧。我心想，天哪，她真烂。
Are there other examples besides Madonna and the internet?
除了麦当娜和互联网还有别的例子吗？
Other than Madonna and the internet, you need another example? When I was an editorial assistant working in publishing, I was handed a manuscript to read. I think I wrote something like, sub-literate, borderline misogyny, an easy pass.
除了麦当娜和互联网，你还需要别的例子？当我做出版业编辑助理时，我收到一份手稿要读。我想我当时写了类似的话：“文化程度低下，边缘厌女症，轻松拒绝。”
And somebody thought, I'm just going to take a look at this anyway. It was Men Are From Mars, Women Are From Venus.
有人心想，我还是打算看一眼。那是《男人来自火星，女人来自金星》。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
These are not like me saying, I don't think Alicia Silverstone is going to be very good in Clueless. I mean, these are like--
这些不像我说“我不认为艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通在《独领风骚》里会表现很好”。我的意思是，这些是像——
Pretty big, iconic ones.
相当大、标志性的例子。
Yeah. It was like, have you fellows heard that crazy lunatic in the market place inveighing against the Pharisees? He'll burn off like so much morning fog. We'll never hear about him ever again. It's just like that.
是的。就像，“伙计们，你们听说那个在市场上斥责法利赛人的疯子吗？他会像晨雾一样散去的。我们永远不会再听说关于他的事了。”就是那样。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
David Rakoff-- the final book that he wrote before he died in 2012 is a book I just love. It's a novel in rhymed couplets-- Love, Dishonor, Marry, Die, Cherish, Perish: A Novel by David Rakoff.
大卫·拉科夫——他在2012年去世前写出的最后一本书是我所钟爱的。这是一部押韵对联的小说——《爱、羞辱、婚姻、死亡、珍惜、毁灭：大卫·拉科夫小说》。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: You're listening to This American Life, where today, it is all about speed. We are, what, 43 minutes into the program and we have already finished 15 acts? And this brings us to Act 16-- That One Guy at the Office. So if you work at a big office, you know that there's always at least one person whose name you do not know. In Jordana's office, Matt is that guy for, perhaps, as best as anybody can figure, half the people who work there. Jordana will tell you about it.
你正在收听《美国生活》，今天，一切都是为了速度。我们已经过去43分钟了，完成了15幕？这带我们到了第16幕——办公室里的那个人。如果你在大公司工作，你知道总有一个人你不知道他的名字。在乔达娜的办公室里，马特就是那个人，对于办公室里一半的人来说，据大家所能推断的。乔达娜会告诉你。
[PRINTER PRINTING]
[打印机打印声]
Matt Ostrower sits next to the printer in the busiest hallway at our office. People walk by him dozens of times a week on their way to retrieve printouts. And though he actually works in the New Media department and has nothing to do with the printer, most people don't know this. It's his sad fate that most of his conversations at work are about one thing.
马特·奥斯特罗威尔坐在办公室最繁忙走廊的打印机旁边。人们每周经过他几十次去拿打印出来的资料。虽然他实际上在“新媒体”部门工作，跟打印机毫无关系，但大多数人不知道这点。他悲剧的命运在于，他在办公室的大部分谈话都关于一件事。
Originally a lot of them were printer-based-- why is this printer taking so long? Oh, the paper's out. Oh, this printer jammed. Some of it's never really left that genre of conversation. They don't really spend too much-- so a lot of it's just very superficial.
起初很多都是基于打印机的——为什么这台打印机这么慢？哦，没纸了。哦，打印机卡纸了。有些谈话从未脱离那个类别。他们真的没花太多——所以很多都是非常肤浅的。
Hey, did you just throw away any printouts here?
嘿，你刚才在这扔过什么打印出来的资料吗？
No, no, I didn't touch anything.
不，不，我什么都没碰。
I'd been working in the office a few months when, one day, a friend called me and said he was hanging out with one of my coworkers who lives in his building. Who, I asked? Matt, he said. I had no idea who that was and said so.
我在办公室工作了几个月后，有一天，一个朋友打电话给我说他正跟一个住在他那栋楼的同事在一起。我问：谁？马特，他说。我根本不知道那是谁，就说了出来。
Then I heard a voice in the background say, tell her I sit next to the printer. And that's when his predicament hit me. So I decided to survey my coworkers to see if they knew who he is, what his real job is. Do they even know his name?
然后我听到背景里有个声音说：告诉她我坐在打印机旁边。就在那时，他的困境击中了我。所以我决定调查一下我的同事，看他们是否知道他是谁，他的真实工作是什么。他们甚至知道他的名字吗？
No, I mean, I know his face very well. I stop, I chat. I say, 'hi, how are you' as I'm grabbing things off the printer.
不，我的意思是，我非常熟悉他的脸。我停下来，聊天。当我从打印机拿东西时，我会说：“嗨，你好吗？”
I ask him about his little electronic music devices and all that, and we chitchat. And I'd say I do that probably about three or four times a day at least. But I have no idea what his name is.
我问他那些电子音乐设备之类的，我们随便聊聊。我想我每天至少会这样三四次。但我根本不知道他叫什么名字。
I wondered if Matt was at all surprised by this.
我想知道马特是否感到惊讶。
Shocked. I honestly see him between 50 and 75 times a day-- different intervals of time-- at least that, every day. Every single day.
震惊。我每天真的会看到他50到75次——不同的时间间隔——至少是这样，每一天。每一天。
I'm wondering if you know the name of the guy that sits right out here in the hallway?
我想知道你是否知道坐在走廊这边的那个人名字？
Is his name-- I don't know. Works on the web, right? Kind of?
他是叫——我不知道。是在网上工作的吧？大概？
And Matt's response?
马特的回答？
I'm a little surprised because I see her every day as well.
我有点惊讶，因为我也每天看到她。
I'm wondering if you know the name of the guy that sits in the hallway next to the printer.
我想知道你是否知道坐在打印机旁边走廊里的那个人名字。
I don't see anybody sitting in the hallway next to the printer. I didn't think we had anybody sitting next to the printer.
我没看到有人坐在打印机旁走廊里。我没想到我们有人坐在打印机旁边。
[PRINTER PRINTING]
[打印机打印声]
I've never had this kind of experience before. The whole situation is just ridiculous-- that I've been here for a year and a half, pretty much every day, and there's still people who don't know my name or what I do. And it's a little bit weird. I could go through a pretty full day without talking to anyone besides the requests from the printer. Sometimes that's it for me. [CHUCKLES]
我以前从没经历过这种体验。整个情况太荒谬了——我在这里待了一年半，几乎每天都在，还是有人不知道我的名字或我是做什么的。这有点奇怪。我可以过完一整天而不跟任何人说话，除了来自打印机的请求。有时对我来说就是这样。[轻笑]
Matt says the printer shows up in his dreams sometimes. In his dreams, he'll be at a party waiting in line for the bathroom, or at a parking lot at the beach, people everywhere. And there will be the printer, off to the side, chugging away, occasionally jamming.
马特说打印机有时会出现在他的梦里。在他的梦里，他在派对上排队等厕所，或者在海滩停车场，到处都是人。然后打印机就在旁边，突突地工作，偶尔卡住。
Jordana Gustafson in Boston.
波士顿的乔达娜·古斯塔夫森。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 17-- You Can't Choose Your Gift.
第十七幕——你无法选择你的天赋。
I'm Richard Cary, and I have this one little talent. I don't know where it came from, and it fears me to think that it's something that I, myself, possess. But I'm able to make the entire sound of a swamp.
我是理查德·卡里，我有这个小天赋。我不知道它从哪来的，想到它是属于我自己的东西，我就感到恐惧。但我能发出整个沼泽的声音。
And I will attempt to do so now. I'm not sure I'm prepared at this moment, but I'll give you the sound of a swamp.
我现在尝试这样做。我不确定我现在准备好了，但我会给你沼泽的声音。
[CROAKING]
[蛙鸣声]
[CRACKLING]
[噼啪声]
[CREAKING]
[吱吱声]
And I don't know why, but it seems to be really important at parties.
我不知道为什么，但这在派对上似乎非常重要。
Richard Cary talked to Jim Sulzer.
理查德·卡里和吉姆·萨尔泽聊过。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 18-- Party Talk. Here's writer Chuck Klosterman.
第十八幕——派对谈话。这里是作家查克·克洛斯特曼。
This was a conversation that happened to me at a party two years ago. At one point in the conversation, I suddenly found it necessary to mention that Journey was rock's version of the TV show Dynasty. This prompted a spirited debate we then dubbed, "Monkees Equals Monkees."
这是两年前我在一个派对上发生的对话。在对话的某个点，我突然觉得有必要提到Journey乐队是摇滚界的《朝代》电视剧版本。这引发了一场我们称之为“猴子等于猴子”的激烈辩论。
The goal of this game is to figure out which television show is the closest philosophical analogy to a specific rock and roll band. And the criteria are mind-blowingly complex. It's a combination of longevity, era, critical acclaim, commercial success, and, most importantly, the aesthetic soul of each artistic entity.
这个游戏的目的是找出哪部电视剧在哲学上最接近某个具体的摇滚乐队。标准复杂得让人震惊。这是寿命、时代、评论赞誉、商业成功，最重要的是，每个艺术实体的审美灵魂的结合。
For example, the Rolling Stones are Gunsmoke. The Strokes-- Kiefer Sutherland's 24. Jimi Hendrix was The Twilight Zone. Devo was Fernwood 2Night.
例如，滚石乐队是《荒野大镖客》。The Strokes是基弗·萨瑟兰的《24小时》。吉米·亨德里克斯是《阴阳魔界》。Devo是《芬伍德之夜》。
Lynyrd Skynyrd was The Beverly Hillbillies, which makes Molly Hatchet Petticoat Junction. The Black Crowes are That 70s Show. Hall and Oates were Bosom Buddies.
Lynyrd Skynyrd是《贝弗利山人》，这使得Molly Hatchet是《佩蒂科特交界处》。Black Crowes是《70年代秀》。Hall and Oates是《贴身伙伴》。
U2 is M.A.S.H. because both kind of got preachy at the end. Dokken was Jason Bateman's short lived sitcom, It's Your Move. The Eurythmics were Mork and Mindy.
U2是《陆军野战医院》，因为两者最后都变得说教。Dokken是杰森·贝特曼的短命情景喜剧《It's Your Move》。Eurythmics是《莫克与明迪》。
We even deduced comparisons for solo projects, which can only be made to series that were spawned as spin-offs. The four Beatles, post-1970, are as follows: John equals Maude, Paul equals Frasier, George equals The Jeffersons, and Ringo equals Flow. David Lee Roth's solo period after Van Halen was Knot's Landing. So there's proof-- marijuana makes you smarter.
我们甚至推断出个人项目的比较，这只能针对作为衍生剧的系列。四个披头士，1970年后，如下：约翰等于《莫德》，保罗等于《弗雷泽》，乔治等于《杰斐逊一家》，林戈等于《弗洛》。范·海伦之后的戴维·李·罗斯的个人时期是《诺茨登陆》。所以证明了——大麻会让你变得更聪明。
Chuck Klosterman reading from his book called Sex, Drugs, and Cocoa Puffs: A Low Culture Manifesto.
查克·克洛斯特曼朗读他那本叫《性、毒品和可可泡芙：低文化宣言》。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 19-- The Hard Life at the Top. Here's a ritual that takes place every summer on the last day of June-- 1,200 new army cadets, mostly teenagers, survivors of one of the most exhausting application processes in the country, arrive at West Point. And then, in the space of one morning, they're separated from their parents. Their clothes are taken away. Their hair is taken away.
第十九幕——巅峰的艰难生活。这是每年六月最后一天举行的仪式——1200名新军校学员，大多是青少年，全国最耗尽心力的申请流程的幸存者，抵达西点军校。然后，在一个上午的时间里，他们被与父母分离。衣服被拿走。头发被剪掉。
They're weighed. They're measured. They're issued a bag, an army uniform, and underwear. They take their oath of office.
他们被称重。被测量。他们拿到一个包、一套军装和内衣。他们进行入职宣誓。
And then, here is the first act they have as non-civilians. All they have to do is say a single sentence. Once they get it said, they can go to their barracks, but not until then. David Lipsky spent four years writing about these guys and describes what happens each year.
然后，这是他们作为非平民的第一个举动。他们只需要说一句话。一旦说出来，他们就可以去兵营了，但在此之前不行。大卫·利普斯基花了四年时间记录这些人，描述了每年发生的事情。
The drill is simple. The new cadets have to step up to a tape line, drop their bags, and make their report to upperclassman wearing red sashes. You will walk up to the line, the red sashes tell them. And you will say, sir, new cadet Doe reports to the cadet and the red sash for the first time as ordered.
演习很简单。新学员必须走到胶带线前，放下包，向佩戴红腰带的高年级学生汇报。你会走到线前，红腰带告诉他们。“你会说：长官，新学员多伊第一次按命令向佩戴红腰带的学员报告。”
The new cadets swallow, nod their heads, and then the screwing up begins. This cadet is so nervous, he doesn't realize he's supposed to swap his own name for Doe.
新学员咽了口唾沫，点点头，然后搞砸就开始了。这个学员太紧张了，没意识到他应该把自己的名字换掉。
Sir, new cadet Doe reports to the cadet--
长官，新学员多伊报告给学员——
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #1: Is your last name Doe?
红腰带 #1：你的姓是多伊吗？
No, sir.
不，长官。
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #1: Then say your name, new cadet.
红腰带 #1：那就说出你的名字，新学员。
Yes, sir.
是，长官。
"Is your last name Doe?" the red sash screams. "No, sir," says the new cadet. "Then say your name, new cadet," says the red sash. Words count, even footwork counts. New cadet Clinker, a jittery 18-year-old female cadet, finds this out when she steps a little too far forward.
“你的姓是多伊吗？”红腰带尖叫道。“不，长官，”新学员说。“那就说出你的名字，新学员，”红腰带说。语言很重要，甚至步法也很重要。新学员克林克，一个紧张的18岁女学员，当她走得太靠前时发现了这一点。
Sir, new cadet Clinker.
长官，新学员克林克。
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #1: New cadet, look where you're standing. I told you to step up to my line. You better learn how to follow orders, new cadet. New cadet--
红腰带 #1：新学员，看看你站在哪。我让你走到我的线前。你最好学会如何听从命令，新学员。新学员——
The red sash asks her to do it again. This time, she stands in the right place, but she's forgotten what to say.
红腰带让她再做一次。这次，她站在正确的位置，但忘记要说什么了。
Sir, new cadet Clinker reports to the--
长官，新学员克林克报告给——
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #2: I tell you to drop it back, you drop it back--
红腰带 #2：我告诉你退后，你就退后——
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #1: Are you showing emotion? Did I just see a smile come across your face, new cadet?
红腰带 #1：你在表现情绪吗？我刚才看到你脸上有笑容了吗，新学员？
No, sir.
不，长官。
(SUBJECT) RED SASH #1: You are like a rock. Maintain your military discipline at all times. You understand, new cadet?
红腰带 #1：你像块石头一样。始终保持你的军事纪律。你明白吗，新学员？
Yes, sir.
是，长官。
For these specially selected red sashes, breaking in the new cadets is a great honor. The day before, they've even practiced being hard on local civilians in a full rehearsal. Every year, a bunch of teachers, sons, daughters, groundskeepers from around town sign up for a fun day as practice cadets. Every year, a handful leave in tears.
对于这些特别挑选的红腰带来说，打破新学员的心理防线是一种巨大的荣誉。前一天，他们甚至在全面排练中演习对当地平民表现得严厉。每年，一堆老师、儿子、女儿、园丁都会报名参加这个有趣的练习学员日。每年，都有少数人哭着离开。
Sir, new cadet McLeod reporting to the cadet in the-- in the red sash for the first time as ordered.
长官，新学员麦克劳德第一次按命令向佩戴——佩戴红腰带的学员报告。
Drop your salute.
放下你的敬礼。
New cadet McLeod stutters on his first attempt. He's asked to drop his salute and start over. On this one day, almost 1,200 young men and women will make their report. If everyone did it right the first time, it would take about an hour. I don't see anyone go through the first time. It takes all day. New cadet McLeod tries again, but the words won't come.
新学员麦克劳德在第一次尝试时结巴了。他被要求放下敬礼重新开始。在这一天，将近1200名年轻男女将进行汇报。如果每个人第一次都做得对，大概需要一小时。我没看到有人一次通过。这花了一整天。新学员麦克劳德再次尝试，但词句就是出不来。
Sir, n-new cadet McLeod-- new--
长官，新——新学员麦克劳德——新——
Drop your salute. [INTERPOSING VOICES]
放下你的敬礼。[交叉声音]
Drop your salute, the red sash tells him. Are you a n-new cadet or a new cadet? New cadet, he says, forgetting the sir.
放下你的敬礼，红腰带告诉他。你是“新学员”还是“新学员”？“新学员”，他说，忘记了“长官”。
New cadet.
新学员。
New cadet, are you going to put a 'sir' on that?
新学员，你打算加上“长官”吗？
Yes, sir.
是，长官。
Poor new cadet McLeod has already screwed up twice. To get here, he spent 18 years excelling in nearly every way he can-- in schoolwork, in athletics, at student council meetings. He's beaten his way to the top of the 50,000 applicants who fill out requests for information forms.
可怜的新学员麦克劳德已经搞砸两次了。为了到达这里，他花了18年几乎在各个方面都追求卓越——在学业上、体育上、学生会会议上。他从5万名填写信息申请表的申请者中脱颖而出。
He's been interviewed by senators, congressmen. And now, here he is, in the last place he ever thought he'd find himself, a sudden death play audition. He only has to say one line. He draws a breath, tries one more time. And after letting go of his family, his hair, his clothes, he drops the last vestige of his civilian life-- he forgets his own name.
他接受过参议员、国会议员的采访。现在，他在这里，在他最没想到的地方，一场突然死亡的表演试镜。他只需要说一句台词。他深吸一口气，再试一次。在抛下家人、头发、衣服后，他丢掉了平民生活的最后遗迹——他忘记了自己的名字。
Sir, new cadet--
长官，新学员——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
David Lipsky-- his book following one cadet class at West Point for four years is called Absolutely American.
大卫·利普斯基——他跟随西点军校一个学员班四年的书叫《绝对美国》。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act 20-- The Greatest Moment I Ever Saw On a Stage. I'll say, first of all, that this moment that I saw caught me completely off guard. I was at a play where I was not expecting anything special. It was put on by an organization that works with teenagers. Storycatchers Theatre is what it's called.
第二十幕——我在舞台上见过的最伟大的时刻。我会先说，我见到的这一刻让我完全措手不及。我当时在看一场演出，根本没预料到会有什么特别。这是一个与青少年合作的组织举办的。它叫“故事捕捉剧院”。
And among other things, they get kids who are locked up in Chicago's juvenile detention center, The Audy Home, to write and perform musicals about their lives. This one was performed by teenage girls. OK, so we're in the detention center. Folding chairs have been set up.
除了其他事情，他们让被关在芝加哥少管所“奥迪之家”的孩子们编写并表演关于他们生活的情景剧。这一个是由少女们表演的。好吧，我们在少管所里。折叠椅已经放好了。
The girls' parents-- it's mostly mothers and grandmothers, very few men-- are sitting directly in front of the stage. And imagine for a minute what it's like to be one of those parents, OK? Your kid's locked up, possibly on very serious charges, some of these girls were. You're worried about what's going to happen to them next. You're probably still mad that they didn't listen to you in the first place and got into all this trouble and ended up behind bars.
女孩们的父母——主要是母亲和祖母，很少有男人——直接坐在舞台前。想象一下，作为其中一个家长是什么感觉？你的孩子被关起来了，可能面临非常严重的指控，有些女孩就是。你担心接下来会发生什么。你可能还在生她们没听你的话、惹出这么多麻烦并进了监狱的气。
What can theater possibly do for you in this situation? It seems like such an old-fashioned idea that it can do anything. So there's this one scene in the play.
在这种情况下，戏剧能为你做什么？这似乎是一个如此老派的想法，它能做任何事。所以演出中有一个场景。
Where'd you get these clothes from?
你的这些衣服从哪来的？
And it's the story of this girl named Candace. And Candace basically wanted better clothes so the other kids at school wouldn't laugh at her. She steal some clothes from Nike Town. And she gets in trouble, she gets caught. And then she joins a gang to earn some money and be more popular.
那是关于一个叫坎迪斯的女孩的故事。坎迪斯基本是因为想要更好的衣服，这样学校里的其他孩子就不会嘲笑她。她在耐克旗舰店偷了一些衣服。她惹了麻烦，被抓住了。然后她加入了一个帮派去赚钱，变得更受欢迎。
Her mom finds some drugs in the house, and a gun, and feels completely betrayed because that was not how she raised her daughter. And one thing leads to another, and Candace gets locked up.
她妈妈在家里发现了一些毒品和一把枪，感到完全被背叛了，因为那不是她抚养女儿的方式。一件接一件事，坎迪斯被关起来了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Then, the girl narrating the story says, and this is how Candace feels about her mom now. And then all the girls in the play come out on the stage and stand in a line, facing their mothers and grandmothers who are right there in front of them.
然后，讲述故事的女孩说：“这就是坎迪斯现在对她妈妈的感觉。” 接着戏里的所有女孩走到舞台上站成一排，面对着她们就在面前的母亲和祖母。
(SINGING) Mama, I'm sorry for what I have done. I was arrested and ended up here in the Audy Home. Oh, I'm sorry for putting you through all of this.
（唱歌）妈妈，我对不起我所做的一切。我被捕了，最终关进了奥迪之家。哦，对不起让你经历了这一切。
I know you are mad about the good times that we missed. I'm ready to come back home. I'm willing to make a change.
我知道你因为我们错过的美好时光而生气。我准备好回家了。我愿意做出改变。
One of the verses goes, "Mama, I'm sorry for making you come to court, for almost losing your job to give me moral support. Mama, I'm sorry for putting your through all this stress, for making you worry yourself and depressed. I'm ready to come back home. I'm willing to make a change."
其中一节歌词是，“妈妈，对不起让你来法庭，对不起差点让你丢了工作来给我精神支持。妈妈，对不起让你承受这一切压力，让你担心自己并感到抑郁。我准备好回家了。我愿意做出改变。”
And, by this time, the girls are all crying, the parents are all crying. And each girl has a cut-out little heart, like on Valentine's Day, like that, made from red construction paper, the size of your palm. And written on each one is the words, "I'm sorry."
到了这个时候，女孩们都在哭，家长们都在哭。每个女孩手里都有一个红色的建筑纸做的小切纸心，像情人节那种，手掌大小。每个上面都写着，“对不起”。
And each girl goes out into the audience to where her mom is sitting, or her grandma is sitting, and hands her the heart. And the parents are crying, and the kids are crying, and everybody is hugging. It was really something.
每个女孩走向观众席妈妈坐的地方，或者祖母坐的地方，把心递给她。家长们在哭，孩子们在哭，每个人都在拥抱。那真是了不起。
(SINGING) --make a change. I'll do anything for you, mom. Please forget about yesterday. Mama, I'm sorry. [SNIFFLES]
（唱歌）——做出改变。妈，我什么都愿意为你做。请忘记昨天。妈妈，对不起。[抽泣]
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Mama, I'm sorry.
对不起。对不起。妈妈，对不起。
Here they were-- not just saying this to their mothers, but saying it publicly in front of the world, in front of their friends. Saying this thing that could be so hard to say in any case. Singing it out and hoping that it can heal something that is going to be hard to heal, no matter what you do.
她们在这里——不仅是对妈妈说这些，而且在世界面前、在朋友面前公开说。说这件在任何情况下都很难说出口的事。唱出来，并希望它能治愈一些无论你做什么都难以治愈的东西。
(SINGING) Mama, I'm sorry. [SNIFFLES] I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Mama, I'm sorry.
（唱歌）妈妈，对不起。[抽泣] 对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。妈妈，对不起。
And that's our show for today, 20 Acts in 60 Minutes. Thanks today to Atlantic Public Media, WCAI and WNAN, our website, thisamericanlife.org.
这就是我们今天的节目，60分钟内20幕。感谢大西洋公共媒体、WCAI和WNAN，我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Tony Malatia, who remembers all the way back to when we started the show.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托尼·马拉蒂亚先生，他记得我们开始这个节目以来的一切。
I think it was right around the time we had this big fight about gumballs, which I'm not going to get into because it's pretty embarrassing.
我记得那正好是我们为口香糖大吵一架的时候，我不打算细说，因为挺尴尬的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。